one american infected with the Ebola
virus in West Africa being treated in
the u.s. at Emory University down in
Atlanta with another one soon to follow
there's the plane that is leaving to
pick up the second patient she's
expected to arrive here in the US on
Tuesday they are the first ever cases of
Ebola on US soil and the move has some
asking why they were brought here in the
first place and does it pose a danger to
Americans Donald Trump tweeting out why
do we need to bring these problems here
to the US you heard that on Friday okay
Washington correspondent Megan Hughes
has been looking into this Megan let's
start with the why who makes the call to
bring these patients within the US
borders it's the charity organizations
that they work with Betty so the two
patients worked in Liberia at different
aid organizations Samaritan's Purse
that's in North carolina-based charity
and si M USA that's a Christian
missionary group that runs the hospital
where they both worked in Liberia so it
was those groups that made the call to
bring them back one of those patients as
you mentioned American dr. Kent Brantly
he was actually well enough to walk into
the hospital over the weekend
his family reports that he's improving
that he's in good spirits the other
worker the other infected worker nancy
writebol he's going she's going to be
joining him there as early as tomorrow
now the organization's say the reason
that they had them transferred back to
the United States Emory is going to be
able to provide better care than the
Liberian hospital where they were being
treated so they're the ones that make
the call but it is the State Department
the CDC the Department of Defense that
handle the logistics basically making
sure that the rest of the country is
safe and that this transfer is done
safely that's right that's the question
in every American's mind so what are
they doing to make sure that this is not
spread well first of all the message
that we're hearing over and over again
from health officials they want people
to realize how this disease is
transmitted it isn't one of these
airborne viruses of bird flu a super
contagious disease
this is person-to-person contact bodily
fluids not airborne so they say because
of hospital infection controls in this
country which are better than West
Africa that makes it very very unlikely
that we'd have a similar outbreak here's
the CDC director over the weekend we do
know how to stop Ebola it's
old-fashioned
simple Public Health find the patients
make sure they treated find their
contacts track them educate people do
infection control in hospitals you do
those things but you have to do them
really well and Ebola goes away then
Betty more specifically to your question
how are officals dealing specifically
with these infected American patients so
the patients they're being transported
in a specialized charter plane it has an
isolation unit they're being flown into
a military airfield near Atlanta so
we're not talking about commercial
flights here and then once they get to
Emory the hospital has a special
isolation unit set up in coordination
with the CDC it's specifically for these
kinds of highly infectious diseases and
Megan in Washington they're gonna be
leaders from 50 act'n countries they're
coming in for a summit with the
president so what about concerns that
they're gonna be flying on commercial
flights and they'll be coming in from
some of the countries where there is a
danger of bringing the Ebola virus and
you can bet that that's a question that
the Obama administration is going to
hear over and over again throughout this
week health officials say it is possible
that we do see some in some new cases
here in the United States but they say
any kind of outbreak here again very
very unlikely the president said last
week they're taking appropriate
precautions and most importantly the
travelers from the countries where this
disease is raging they're going to be
going through extra health screenings on
the ground in Africa before they even
get on any us-bound flights